لَوْنِي جَذَّابٌ مَحْبُوبَةْ
مَنْ يَعْرِفُنِيْ يَا أَطْفَالْ
وَأُقَدِمُ أَيْضًا مَشْرُوبًا
أَنَا انا أنااا البُرْتُقَالْ
لَوْنِي جَذَّابٌ مَحْبُوبَةْ
مَنْ يَعْرِفُنِيْ يَا أَطْفَالْ
وَأُقَدِمُ أَيْضًا مَشْرُوبًا
أَنَا انا أنااا البُرْتُقَالْ
أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة
أَنَا أَنَا أَنَا
أَحْمِي مِنْ نَزَلاَتِ البَرْدِ وأُقَوِي مَنَاعَتَكَ بِجِد
أُعْطِيكَ بِأَكْلِي فِيتَامِينْ  أَجْعَلُ خَدَّيْكَ كَالوَرْدِ
أنا أَحْمِي مِنْ نَزَلاَتِ البَرْدِ وأُقَوِي مَنَاعَتَكَ بِجِد
أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة
أَنَا أَنَا أَنَا
إِنِّي بِالأَلْيَافِ غَنِيَّةْ  ومُفِيدَةْ جِدًا لِلْهَضْمِ
بِالطَاقَةِ أُعْطِي الحَيَوِيَّةْ  وأُخَفِضُ مِنْ ضَغْطِ الدَّمْ
لا لا لا لا لا
أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة
بُرْتُقَالَة
لا لا لا لا لا
أَحْفَظُ قَلْبَكَ وأُقَوِّيِهْ  لِيَظَلَ صَحِيِحًا وَأَقِيهْ
بِتَنَاوُلِ حَبَّاتٍ مِنِّي  مِنْ خَيْرِي الوَافِرِ أُعْطِيهْ
أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة
أَنَا أَنَا أَنَا
أَنَا فَاكِهَة البُرْتُقَالْ  الصِّحَةَ أُعْطِي وَجَمَالْ
وأَقِي مِنْ شَرِّ الأَمْرَاضْ  وأُحِبُ جَمِيعَ الأَطْفَالْ
لَوْنِي جَذَّابٌ مَحْبُوبَةْ  مَنْ يَعْرِفُنِيْ يَا أَطْفَالْ
وَأُقَدِمُ أَيْضًا مَشْرُوبًا  أَنَا انا أنااا البُرْتُقَالْ
أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة
أَنَا أَنَا أَنَا
لا لا لا لا لا
أَنَا بُرْتُقَالَة